we got a little relationship advice boy
I can't tell you so many people you
saved my marriage oh my god my life my
life is so much better cuz you wouldn't
see oh [ __ ] dr. drew it's doctor job and
dr. Vaughn I'm like alright relax
first of all why does his son laugh like
an ak-47 that is very alarming dog sorry
Sam but that is I didn't realize it - I
didn't either very much a warning sound
when people were like oh we didn't see
it coming we never knew he could do it
nopales on giving all the clues dressed
like a parrot
laughs like an ak-47 dressing he's
totally trying to blend in in the south
or something like he's gonna bomb a
NASCAR event let me sum Dale Earnhardt
jr. from Armani that's been the Mountain
Dew Code Red what else we get we got
this is Josh from India oh yeah Bobby
Yosh heavy one Brendan I'm sending you
guys a question
so brought my best friend and my what a
car you can tell he's a good dude love
you - Yoshi thank you say this in and
not much better than the guy who tried
to kill his dog on her watch more videos
like this less about abusing animals I'm
still very insane that dog jumped
straight into a parked car they say I
speak a decently high speeds dog hole
and the Raider signed him after that
so that's
[Laughter]
don't touch me but you keep touching me
especially to tan like your tan dude you
look like somebody who definitely wants
to just say that they drive a yellow cab
bro like and you cannot you just no
other way you have to let people know
what I do bro I could see it man
I like this duty as a good heart dude
best friends can made to his
ex-girlfriend
I'll see not very good bass friend also
how long did you guys date for if you
date four years that's [ __ ] up few
months dude you were just a cock-block
on the way to them getting married so
it's all good I need more details you
know I'm saying I don't need any more
details man oh yeah we've got a million
details and still have nothing going on
Brendan yeah what I must say is this
right here young fella is that I think
if you if you have any feelings for the
girl probably I think you probably just
don't go you know you don't want it to
be weird for them I think it's like it's
their day yeah you're right
you're awfully not in the picture dude
you don't wanna go the wedding get all
drunk and then they're like god that's
sad you know yeah oh yeah you don't want
to get sad like what if you get sad or
something then people see you being sad
or you feel uncomfortable like I would
just even for yourself I would just
maybe just you know go do something else
now I know sometimes in India the
weddings like three or four days long so
it might be that everybody's gonna be
there
and there's nowhere else even though you
might not even be able to escape the
wedding some of the weddings are so big
part of it like a Latin or some [ __ ] you
could drive two miles
yeah here's the other thing or maybe I
don't know you good-looking dude over
there in India maybe get to some
drop-dead milla keel off where the [ __ ]
that porn stars name is get her on your
arm and roll into that wet and just drip
on everybody bro just start throwing
beads like it's Mardi Gras dude
I start seeing they're flexing on him
dude but riding on a white horse bro
no rent a jeep ride ride the white horse
if you ride in on a white horse dude
people are gonna be like oh what's up
with this guy not everybody is not on
white horses in India so you could do
that
you're Arabian horses they're brown dude
Arabian think about it also maybe write
in on a Gila monster just flip the
script dude and just have some girls
some sand hitters in the mouth enough
some other lizard back sneaking into the
country brothers you know that's the
last thing they need let's ask a woman
we have cat here who's a woman he
shouldn't go that's gonna bum him out
especially for three days if he goes to
every single wedding event yeah that's
you don't want to be that guy what if he
went with a what why I don't know I need
more details how long did they date for
it's just a few weeks get over dude but
if it's a while dude show up with it
what about that cat what if he showed up
with just a [ __ ] dime piece drip and
it was like who makes the girl getting
married look like [ __ ] Samuel Jackson
but then he's still gonna have
everything we'll see her and realize
always with a hot girl he's still stuck
there with his own feelings being like
oh now I'm bummed out and I gotta keep
watching this girl eat you know and
drink stuff that's a good point dude so
yeah you'd want to be there for two and
a half days was you know with a lady you
might not really be into I just wouldn't
go man I think he probably liked the
girl enough that he's sending this
message yeah you can tell he's kind of
heard about it say you're out of town
yeah you could say you're out of town
dude you're a closer I'd fly you here
you could hang out with us we're in
India so too far
yeah that's far that's way too far dude
oh good luck though man I'd say don't go
yeah I would say don't go man you seem
like a nice guy I'm sure you got other
opportunities for some you know for some
good women out there so you know in the
Bollywood what do you think you saw
Nissan's from from far away from here I
think split the difference go to like
one of the days one of the one of the
less important days bad idea coming at
the end where everyone's tired he's full
of energy right what it's not a [ __ ]
Royal Rumble dude no you've never been
in Indian wedding yes it is yes it is
dude one point they throw chalk dust at
everybody it's crazy bro at one point
just put a cage around the whole family
never gets out
what else we got good luck dude
[Music]